يرقصون في جنائز موتاهم لسته ايام متواصله
ويعتقدون ان اقنعتهم هذه لها دور كبير في
توجيه ارواح الموتى الى الحياه الاخرى
عرفوا نجم الشعر ومدارك كوكب زحل قبل الاف
السنين ودون استخدام اي تكنولوجيا
انهم شعب الدوجون
في منطقه الهضبه الوسطى في مالي بغرب
افريقيا يعيش شعب الدوجون وهم قبائل عرقيه
تعرف بانها الاكثر شده وصلابه وقوه بين
القبائل الافريقيه
تاريخهم ممتد لالاف السنين ورغم عدم وجود
احصاء رسمي لتعدادهم تشير التقديرات الى
ان عددهم يتراوح بين 400 الف نسمه
وثمانمائه الف قبائل الدوجون لديها طقوس
غريبه لا يخلو بعضها من الطرافه فان
ارادوا جني محاصيل وفيره رقصوا وان قرروا
خوض حرب وهميه تجديدا لتراثهم العسكري
رقصوا ايضا عند دفن موتاهم يفعلون ما لا
يستوعبه العقل البشري
يرقصون في الجنازه لسته ايام مقنعين بهذه
الاقنعه المرتبطه بارواح الموتى كما
يزعمون ولكل قناع معنى مختلف بحسب القريه
التي ينتمون اليها لكن وبصفه عامه اصبحت
طقوسهم الجنائزيه اشبه بالعروض الفلكلوريه
التي شكلت لاحقا عنصر جذب رئيسيا للسياح
الى مناطقهم
الاقنعه في شكلها الاصلي تمثل كل تفكيرنا
الفلسفي والاجتماعي والثقافي كل قناع له
اهميته كل قناع له مانع كل منها رمز لشيء
ما
المثير في قبائل الدوجون هو الغموض الفلكي
وادعائهم انهم على درايه بعلوم الفضاء
والكواكب منذ الاف السنين بعض المصادر
تشير الى ان حكماء القبيله تحدثوا ووصفوا
بدقه اجراما سماويه تحتاج لمناظير عملاقه
لكشفها العالم روبرتامبل في كتابه لغز
الشعره قال ان شعب الدوجون كانت لهم
اتصالات بكائنات فضائيه قبيحه وبرمائيه
قبل نحو خمسه الاف سنه جاءت الى تلك
المنطقه من كوكب يدور حول نجم الشعر لسبب
غير معروف ويبدو انها لم تقدم شيئا لابناء
الارض سوى اعطائهم بعض المعلومات الفلكيه
العديمه الجدوى على حد وصفه الكثير من
الباحثين اعترضوا على روايه الكائنات
الفضائيه
معتبرين ان معارفهم الفلكيه وصلت اليهم من
الحضاره المصريه القديمه فبعض المصادر
تشير الى علاقه وطيده كانت بين قدماء
المصريين وشعب الدوجون لكن يبقى القول
الاقرب الذي اكده العلماء ان كل ذلك مجرد
اساطير لا ترقى الى مستوى التاكيد